pirineo baluk y su esposa susana rudik
siguen atentos las noticias de la guerra
en ucrania irineo no puede evitar el
recuerdo de su propia salida de ese país
sobre el final de la segunda guerra
mundial aquí está el tactics muestra
orgulloso este tapiz que su abuela les
hizo poner a su familia en el carro para
viajar más cómodos y que aún conserva
justamente ahora cuando yo lo veo este y
me pone el lugar y se me mire se me se
me humedecen los ojos porque me pongo en
el lugar de ellos que ellos también
estaban dos días cinco años y ahora
medio también están otros jóvenes que
también padecen lo que yo ya padecía y
por suerte lo pude superar y deseos de
que ellos también superen
para manifestar su rechazo a la guerra a
la comunidad ucraniana en argentina ya
realizó varias marchas en buenos aires
como esta frente a la embajada rusa en
la que estuvo irineo o esta otra en la
plaza de mayo en la que había algunas
ucranianos recientemente llegados al
país angustiados por lo que ocurre en su
tierra si antes estaba viendo en buenos
aires ahora estoy viviendo en internet
estoy viviendo en noticias en chats con
mi familia cada mañana y cada noche es
como estáis estáis bien estáis bien y
cuando llevan a horas sin contestar eso
te asusta
mientras tanto irineo y susana se reúnen
con sus hijos en su casa para compartir
novedades de sus parientes en ucrania
irineo y susana que es hija de
inmigrantes ucranianos son católicos de
rito oriental de la iglesia bizantina yo
como católico
apoyo la oración que para mí
en la oración es importante por eso en
el fondo espero que
evite un milagro vote por en la
comunidad ucraniana argentina cada uno a
su manera irineo y susana rezando piden
por el final de la guerra en la que está
sumida en su tierra ancestral traspasa
la luz